dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on a fajir have you
heard of the Ken Burns effect if you
have been watching this channel you have
probably seen examples where a still
image is shown and a zooming and panning
effect is added to it it looks something
like this
familiar right the fact that there is
some motion is indeed pleasing for the
eye but something is missing since we
are doing this with 2d images all the
depth information is lost so we are
missing out on the motion parallax
effect that we would see in real life
when moving around the camera so in
short this is only 2d can this be done
in 3d well to find out have a look at
this
Wow I love it much better right well if
we would try to perform something like
this without this paper
we'd be met with bad news and that bad
news is that we have to buy an RGB D
camera this kind of camera in douse the
2d image with depth information which is
specialized hardware that is likely not
available in our phones as of the making
of this video
now since depth estimation from this
simple monocular 2d images without depth
data is a research field of its own the
first step
sounds simple enough take one of those
neural networks then ask it to try to
guess the depth of each pixel does this
work well let's have a look as we move
our imaginary camera around oh this is
not looking good do you see what the
problems are here problem number one is
the presence of geometric distortions
you see it if you look here
problem number two is referred to as
semantic Distortion in the paper or in
other words we now have missing data but
this poor tiny humans hand is also a
ouch let's look at something else
instead if we start zooming in into
images which is a hallmark of the Ken
Burns effect it gets even worse we get
art effects so how does this new paper
address these issues after creating the
first course depth map an additional
step is taken to alleviate the semantic
distortion issue and then this depth
information is up sampled to make sure
that we have enough fine details to
perform the 3d Ken Burns effect let's do
that unfortunately we are still nowhere
near done yet previously occluded parts
of the background suddenly become
visible and we have no information about
those so how can we address that do you
remember image in painting I hope so but
if not no matter I'll quickly explain
what it is both a learning-based and
traditional handcrafted algorithms exist
to try to fill in this missing
information in images with sensible data
by looking at its surroundings this is
also not as trivial as it might seem
first for instance just filling in
sensible data is not enough because this
time around we are synthesizing videos
it has to be temporally coherent which
means that there must not be too much of
a change from one frame to another or
else we'll get a flickering effect
as a result we finally have these
results that are not only absolutely
beautiful but the user study in the
paper shows that they stack up against
handcrafted results made by real artists
how cool is that it also opens up really
cool workflows that would normally be
very difficult if not impossible to
perform for instance here you see that
we can freeze this lightning bolt in
time zoom around and marvel at the
entire landscape
love it of course limitations still
apply if we have really thin objects
such as this flagpole it might be
missing entirely from the death map or
there are also cases where the image in
painter cannot fill in useful
information I cannot wait to see how
this work evolves a couple papers down
the line one more interesting tidbit if
you have a look at the paper make sure
to open it in Adobe Reader you will
likely be very surprised to see that
many of these things that you think are
still images are actually animations
papers are not only getting more
mind-blowing by the day but also more
informative and beautiful as well what a
time to be alive this video has been
supported by you on patreon if you wish
to support the series and also pick up
cool perks in return like early access
to these episodes or getting your name
immortalized in the video description
make sure to visit us through
patreon.com slash two minute papers
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time